[Music]
on this Thursday night the deadline to
crack down on the world's longest border
new details on how soon it could happen
there is nothing we won't do to keep you
safe plus the struggle to enforce social
distancing Italy's morbid milestone the
staggering number of deaths from the
crisis overwhelming that country and
pumping out necessities we're supplying
some of the some of the old folks homes
the distilleries lending a helping hand
during the pandemic good evening and
thank you for joining us we are once
again focusing our program tonight on
the Cova 19 pandemic from the latest
measures to tackle the virus to the
efforts to get stranded Canadians home
we have full coverage of this fast
changing situation but we begin tonight
with a grim update from overseas Italy
which for weeks has been overrun by
cases has now officially surpassed
China's death toll Italian officials
reported 427 more deaths today that sent
the overall death toll surging past 3400
and that's what Canada is trying to
prevent but health experts and the
government warned the worst is yet to
come
they're urging people to stay home
here's what the prime minister said
today when asked how long will this last
we've heard anything from weeks to
months we know this is a difficult and
extraordinary time in which Canadians
are taking difficult and extraordinary
measures and we will continue to do that
until Canadians are safe three more
deaths were reported today in Canada
Alberta recorded its first a man in his
60s a man in his 50s died in Ontario and
there was another death NBC connected to
a North Vancouver seniors care home that
brings the total number of deaths to 12
as for total infections more than 860
people have tested positive of those at
least 10 people have recovered all 10
provinces have detected the virus in six
provinces 20 or fewer people have tested
positive most of Canada's cases are in
BC Ontario Alberta and Quebec public
health officials are pounding home the
message stay home a collective resolve
to overcome Kovan 90 must be solid and
unbendable we don't just need to flatten
the curve we need to plank it and we
need everyone from government to
communities families and individuals to
work together the federal government
revealed plans yesterday to shut down
the US Canada border to non-essential
travel to help slow the spread of the
virus there are new details tonight on
when that might happen
here's Mike Armstrong even a full day
after announcing the closure of a
canada-us border negotiations continue
the prime minister says the plan is to
close it effective Saturday morning but
the deals still not done we are
continuing to work on the fine-tuning of
the agreement between Canada United
States I think it's almost there the two
governments are trying to delicately
balance the importance of cutting off
non-essential travel while at the same
time ensuring trucks and workers who do
have to cross can and easily
critical food and medicine and supplies
have to keep moving the border isn't
closed yet but the government is
appealing to Canadians to treat it as
though it is don't wait for Saturday to
do this
now the border closure is part of the
entire social isolation effort to slow
transmission and flatten the curve to
this point 83% of kovat 19 cases in
Canada have been traced to travel but
those positive tests were from
transmission that happened a week and
two weeks ago how well social isolation
is working won't be known for a couple
of weeks from now so what I would like
to see and I'll be watching very closely
is then that next two weeks or so what
actually happens that curve one area
where the government is struggling is
getting Canadians home with airlines
parking more and more of their fleets
options for travelers abroad or drying
up and it's getting harder and harder to
land planes in countries that are also
dealing with this crisis it's a very
complex situation we understand how
frightening it is for people know the
Prime Minister was asked about Canadians
who traveled recently and are stuck
perhaps due to their own carelessness
should taxpayers have to foot the bill
to bring them back
well Justin Trudeau says right now the
government's not judging people it's
worrying about helping people Robin Mike
Armstrong in Ottawa thanks Mike with the
virus spreading restrictions in this
country are growing by the day many
communities have banned large gatherings
and ordered the shutdown of bars and
restaurants at least one province has
unveiled strict penalties for anyone who
fails to comply
David akin has more on the aggressive
push to flatten the curve
[Music]
airlines are already letting only
Canadian citizens or permanent residents
board planes bound for Canada but
airlines are also being told that no one
not even a Canadian citizen gets on a
plane bound for Canada if that traveler
is exhibiting any kovat 19 symptoms
those that show up at the gate with a
dry cough fever or other flu-like
symptoms will be required to do one of
two things complete a 14-day isolation
and return to the airport symptom free
or get a medical certificate certifying
that the symptoms are not related to Co
vat19 this could mean that some
Canadians could be delayed returning
home we're focused on trying to get the
our air air operator's to to facilitate
more flights to get Canadians home we
recognize that this is a very difficult
and exceptional situation as for inter
provincial travel Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau is not prepared to set
restrictions on that now while Ontario's
premier said he was reluctant to have
police or other authorities and force
social distancing guidelines people are
cooperating and we can't do this by
really you know going out there and
enforcing it we need their cooperation
provincial and local public health
officials already have significant legal
powers including the powers to levy
fines or even seek jail times in order
to enforce coroutines but those powers
vary and are generally seen as a last
resort if someone's particularly high
risk to someone else's health that you
know such approaches can be exercised
but one is not aiming for that to be the
key response still the federal cabinet
met Thursday afternoon and as the Prime
Minister said before joining that
meeting the cabinet is still considering
what if any new emergency powers it
ought to have and when they ought to be
applied Robin
David akin in Ottawa Irving has
suspended all industrial operations at
its shipyard in Halifax for a three week
period as a result of the Cova 19
pandemic the shut down at Halifax
shipyard marine fabricators and Woodside
Industries went into effect this
afternoon
about 1,100 unionized workers have been
laid off the shipyard has federal
contracts for six Arctic and offshore
patrol vessels and for 15 Canadian
surface combatant ships south of the
border the number of confirmed Kovan 19
cases has surged past 10,000 that number
is expected to grow even more in the
coming days the governor of California
says projections show 56 percent of his
state could get the virus that's 25
million people in California alone
across the u.s. health officials are
sounding the alarm about a severe
shortage of essential supplies
but as Jackson prosecco reports the
White House insists it's managing the
response as US hospitals begin to buckle
under the weight of the new coronavirus
doctors and nurses issued a grim plea
for more supplies to treat patients and
to protect themselves in ICU we see the
people coding we see the people on the
ventilator there's lots of unanswered
questions with a dire shortage of
protective masks and ventilators the US
Centers for Disease Control relaxed its
guidelines suggesting medical workers
with exposure to kovat 19 but with no
symptoms can keep working advising they
wear scarfs and bandanas if they run out
of masks but in Washington the president
was unwilling to entertain any
suggestion of a failure to prepare the
only thing we weren't prepared for was
the the media the media has not treated
it fairly
after weeks of delay the u.s. is now
relaxing laws to allow construction
masks to be used by medical workers
asking for existing antiviral drugs used
to treat malaria to be tested on
coronavirus patients to determine if an
experimental or an off-the-shelf drug
that's used for something else can
safely and effectively treat patients as
testing improves the number of confirmed
cases has skyrocketed there are now more
than 3,600 in New York City alone two
members of Congress are confirmed to
have the virus several more are in
isolation as lawmakers debate a trillion
dollar economic rescue
Paquette the trajectory of infection
suggests the u.s. is on the same grim
path as Italy facing an unprecedented
crisis Jaxson Prosecco Global News
Washington
the number of cases in Spain jumped 25%
overnight in France 18 percent now the
Khan Film Festival arguably the world's
most prestigious film event is being
postponed but there's new alarm in Italy
tonight as Redman Shannon reports the
death toll there has now surpassed China
the Italian Army on the streets of
Bergamo not to protect the living but to
transport the dead the northern city is
overwhelmed with bodies so many of the
victims are being moved for burial
elsewhere nurses and physicians are
working round the clock countless hour
to fight this incredible situation Italy
is now overtaking China in total
coronavirus deaths with a staggeringly
high fatality rate the nationwide
lockdown is set to be extended beyond
next Wednesday a crisis worsened by Mani
hospital staff testing positive -
contagious oh no don t see me amaura
theme we're not even counting the dead
anymore says this nurse our stress is
through the roof here in the UK the
government is being criticized for being
too slow in encouraging and demanding
social distancing but on Friday schools
closed indefinitely and bit by bit
London is grinding to a halt some subway
stations are closed but British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson said there is no
prospect of a full lockdown in the
capital we can turn the tide within the
next 12 weeks and I'm absolutely
confident that we can send a coronavirus
backing in this country but only if we
take the steps we won't take the steps
that we have outlined those steps
include staying away from bars and
restaurants even though they're still
allowed to stay open always an optimist
Johnson says there is hope
initiations today to my antibody test as
simple as a pregnancy test they can tell
whether the disease the idea to allow
people out of isolation as the crisis
subsides but the focus for now is
managing a disaster that is yet to peak
Redmon Shannon Global News London the
Queen and Prince Philip have arrived at
Windsor Castle where they're expected to
remain during this pandemic the 93 old
monarch was seen leaving Buckingham
Palace today in a statement she urged
Britain's now more than at any time in
our recent past we all have a vitally
important part to play as individuals
you can be assured that my family and I
stand ready to play our part Prince
Albert of Monaco is also urging people
to take proper precautions after he
tested positive the palace says the
royal status is not worrying at all the
62 year old is believed to be the first
head of state to public confirm having
contracted the virus frustration and
optimism on the front lines coming up
how health care workers feel and their
message to the public
anxiety frustration and a sense of duty
those are some of the emotions being
felt by health care workers on the front
lines during the biggest health crisis
of our time heather York's West shows us
how some are coping and their concerns
looking forward inside this Toronto
hospital health care workers are getting
ready to face a challenge unlike
anything they've ever seen the situation
that we're seeing is unprecedented I
think for frontline physicians there is
an element of frustration and that we
feel we know what needs to be done today
to protect the public from the resource
limitations that we foresee dr. michael
warner says government messages about
social distancing haven't been strong or
consistent enough he feels more needs to
be done social distancing cannot be done
in half measures has to be done by
everybody that means that from my
perspective it's not okay to congregate
in groups of less than 50 in Alberta dr.
Wendy's legal is more optimistic I think
that we've seen in the last couple of
days very aggressive measures taken by
our government and I feel quite
reassured that that most non-essential
services have essentially been shut down
this ICU physician believes the next
three to six months will be incredibly
challenging but she says the public can
help health care workers by staying calm
I think a lot of the fears you know
again I think can be potentially people
can be reassured by knowing that we are
prepared to handle this pandemic and
panic will only impede our success in
managing this much of the health systems
success will depend on what all
Canadians do now it's why some frontline
workers have been taking their appeals
to social media this post by a nurse
from Ontario has been shared more than
100,000 times this is a matter of life
and death Ashley McIntosh barton rights
stop being selfish and think of everyone
else who is already fighting for their
lives this is what we trained for this
is why we chose this job because
whatever happens next frontline workers
are committed to help they just need to
know they're not in this fight alone
Heather your exbest Global News Calgary
can Cova 19 be spread through surfaces
still ahead experts answer your
questions here's a heartwarming note
that should put a smile on your face a
Canadian kid got a rare response from
the Prime Minister after writing him a
letter about Kovan 19 the eight-year-old
said please do your best I don't want it
to get to any of my grandparents the
Prime Minister responded with we're
working super hard to slow down the
spread and keep you your grandparents
and all Canadians safe many of you also
have concerns about the virus and have
been reaching out to us our Jeff sample
went to the experts to get some answers
so Jeff what's the latest on how long it
can live on surfaces
well Robin health experts say that kovat
19 isn't airborne but as instead spread
through droplets that are created when
someone coughs or sneezes and are often
then spread on different surfaces and
that's prompting a lot of viewers to ask
this hi my name is lil Ronald's and I'm
calling from Vancouver British Columbia
and my question is how long does the co
vid 19 virus last on different types of
surfaces different surfaces that can
last up to a couple of days a new report
found that the virus can survive on
cardboard for up to 24 hours and on a
plastic surface for two to three days
meaning someone could COFF on this bench
and a couple of days later someone comes
by touches the bench rubs their eye and
gets infected the virus is less likely
to survive on porous materials such as
clothing or pet fur depends on the
surface the temperature in the humidity
hi my name is Sam my wife live in
Vancouver BC and we are almost 20 weeks
pregnant and I was wondering if pregnant
women are in fact more susceptible
fortunately the little information we do
have would suggest that pregnant women
are not at an increased risk of getting
this and there's even doubt as to
whether the virus can pass through the
placenta and effect infect the fetus on
the streets of Toronto these days
it's not uncommon to see people walking
around wearing one of these a surgical
mask or even the professional-grade n95
respirator my name is Barbara
I live in Keswick Ontario I was
wondering would masks help in this case
experts say there's no evidence to
support wearing masks and users are
often more likely to touch their face so
the only reason to wear a mask is if you
are sick he says the best advice is to
avoid gatherings even in small numbers
but one viewer wrote to say that it
seems there are a number of people
choosing to ignore this self isolation
mandate the st. Patrick's Day
celebrations at Queen's University went
ahead despite warnings from officials I
have a compromised immune system but I'm
still only 21 but I'm not even worried
if you get this disease and you have the
sniffles and a fever it doesn't mean
that the person you pass it to who could
be your parents or someone else you care
about won't have completely different
symptoms and them they could die because
you passed it to them if you do the math
the result is grisly conservative
estimates suggests that around a third
of Canadians will catch Cove in 19 and
that 1% of those will die meaning more
than a hundred thousand Canadians are
expected to be killed by the coronavirus
this year
Robin thanks for that information Jeff
one question that remains unanswered
whether or not the Tokyo Olympics will
be held this summer the International
Olympic Committee has said the games
could still begin on July 24th despite
the pandemic but Canadian hailing wicken
Heiser believes that's the wrong move I
mean nobody knows what's happening with
his virus today let alone tomorrow let
alone four months from now and I just
feel that the the insistence that the
games are going to happen in July is
doing a disservice the sixth time
Olympian posted this statement on
Twitter raising concerns for athletes
and the general public
Joaquin Heiser is studying to become a
doctor and has witnessed the efforts to
contain the virus up next that's the
spirit the proof that innovation can
help slow the spread
of Cova 19
it's been called liquid gold stores are
selling out of hand sanitizer as quickly
as they can stock it so some
distilleries are seizing the opportunity
to help by brewing up some of their own
Ross Lord reports on the Canadian
companies pumping out a new product
dipping into the disinfectant market was
a reluctant move for Nova Scotia's ayran
works distillery there's a lack of hand
sanitizers on the shelves which is not
something one would ever have expected
but it became apparent that we had a
product that would do the job they're
using the same main ingredient alcohol
just increasing the concentration to 65%
the recommended level for killing germs
we've had people breaking down the doors
on Instagram and Facebook and other
social media channels already because
they want it and they can't find it
anywhere
no one knows how long this makes you if
the rain will last but here at ironworks
they hope it's short-term because that
would mean the covert crisis has eased
like many Canadians Lin Mackay has an
emotional connection a close family
member has been stuck in the United
States flight plans were coming home
have been complicated
Iron Works is paying extra excise tax
just to get hundreds of these bottles
out at the door
well we're supplying some of the some of
the old folks homes if they asked for it
some of the shops in town who might have
a need because they can't find anything
other distilleries are also helping out
this one in Halifax plans to give away
its hand sanitizer as it sorts out kinks
in the supply chain that make it tough
to find additional bottles this was kind
of like a curveball that sort of just
started you know within two two days
which was like okay we need to kind of
jump on this and see what we can do
others are still sorting out
distribution confident demand for their
new products is unlikely to fade anytime
soon doing their small part to counter a
big problem Ross lore global news
Lunenburg Nova Scotia and that is global
national for this Thursday I'm Robin
Gill tonight we leave you with a
friendly reminder from BC
[Music]
stay home is what these brothers call
their self isolation song it's on
YouTube where you can find the lyrics
and sing along from home thank you for
watching good night
[Music]